hello everyone and welcome back to game
13 of the 1972 World Chess Championship
match between Boris positive its passkey
and robert james fisher now ever since
Spassky surprised Fischer in game 11
with that poisoned pawn variation of the
night off game 12 was well it was a
pretty feisty game but it ended in a
draw and now once again is game 13 a
chance for Spassky to lower Fischer's
lead in this match and once again
Spassky will happily open the game with
the King's pawn now it's I think it's
important to mention that up to this
point in the match Fischer already first
requested the first three rows of the
audience to be removed so they had to go
three rows back so he wouldn't hear
whispering then he requested another two
rows to be removed and now before game
13 he requested that another seven rows
would be removed so the chief arbiter a
lot of it asked him but you know where
will the audience sit and this is this
is something that he said that it was up
to the organizers to figure out and then
he contacted the Fischer's Fisher's
lawyer and his advisor and he told him
that that's not not something you can do
and Fischer's were replied that he's
here to complain not to approve I
thought that was a very interesting and
also Fischer requested that if there are
any children in the audience watching
the match that no candy should be
allowed as the unwrapping of the candy
is you know and it makes him very
nervous but I am getting back to the
game it's game 13 and Spassky opens with
like we said the King's pawn we have
efore on the board and here everyone
thought that Fischer would improve on
the poisoned pawn variation of the night
off and try to prove that he is indeed
the best but it seems that for now he
decides not to go for this so here
Fischer all plays Knight to f6 so for
the first time in the match we have
aliens defense e5 by Spassky advancing
the pawn we have Knight to d5 and now d4
d6 this is the classical variation
Knight to f3 and g6 now we have Bishop
to c4 at
the night here nights the b6 attacking
the bishop and the bishop back to b3
brush up to g7 and now comes Knight B to
d2 this is a most busky spend a lot of
time over the board
and it's not that often this move is
played very often in this position a4
was plated this is a famous Karras move
Paul Carrack used this to beat a lot of
other players and also nice the g5 is
very interesting taking this advantage
of the early attack against the f7 point
I remember I once had this position on
the board and I was very happy that I
had this Knight to g5 move because black
has to react to this heater he can
either castle or push e six and for
example if east six then you can either
castle but better is pushing f4
immediate and now I won black gets rid
of your knife from g5 you get tonight
back to f3 and now instead of this pawn
mingun f f2 blocked by our Knight
your phone is already very nicely
advanced on f4 your knight is developed
you're ready to castle play c3 and end
what not but Spassky had a different
idea for this game he plays Knight B to
d2 and okay Fischer castles we have h3
h3 was characterized as kind of a loss
of time because yes you do want to
prevent Bishop to g4 were black with
pressure denied pin denied and then this
D captures on e5 would definitely be an
idea but preventing it prematurely is is
to be considered a loss of time so how
does Fischer take advantage of it he
pushes a 5 attack prepares to attack
spassky's bishop with a 4 and here
Spassky defends it would pay for he
doesn't allow for her to push a for
himself but now it really shows how
Fischer can tackle any position and now
Fischer's plan is to play Knight to a6
exchange in the center bring this Knight
over to c5 and the wood Queen to e8
create a triple attack against this a4
pawn so let's see how Fischer does it D
captures on e5 like we said D captors on
e5 and now Knight to a6 as he cleared
the c5 square are creating a very nice
outpost for his Knight and witch Queen
to e8 he will create a triple attack
against the DEA for pawn so there's
really no good way to prevent this if
you
something like c3 to make room for the
bishop on c2 and push b3 to defend upon
again nice to see five and now the night
is coming to v3 would check and the
White has a lot of problems here so
after a night to a six possibly decides
to give up this pawn and you know go for
a very active game with the white pieces
he castles and fish or simply continues
we have Knights to c5 as planned
Queen to e2 by Spassky and the now comes
Queen to e8 now with a triple attack
against the a4 pawn and Spassky goes
nice to e4 either offering an exchange
or forcing Fischer to go for this pawn
grabbing idea official decides to grab
the point Knight be capped resume for
Bishop captures an a4 Knight captures an
a4 and here a very interesting moment
where Spassky could to try and equalize
in material will remove like Queen to c4
this comes with a double attack against
the knight on e4 and also with an attack
against the c7 point and after Bishop to
d7 defending now Queen could capture on
c7 but then after coming to c8 forcing
the Queen trade because you're now
attacking the c2 pawn queen captures
rook F captures a black would have a
much more active position he would also
have the bishop pair B b5 is coming and
it's it's simply a much better game for
black so after Knight to a4 rook to e1
simply improving the position for white
tonight back to b6 by Fischer if he
wants to include the knight back into
the game and also say that he just has
an extra pawn and that if he finishes
his development that he will have a
better game Bishop to d2 attacking the
pawn and Fischer simply pushes it a 4
here now Spassky admits that his Bishop
isn't doing all that much on d2 sake
removers at Bishop to g5 and now h6
again Fischer asked Spassky what what
are you doing with this Bishop we have
rush up to h4 and now comes the Bishop
to f5 Fischer develops is the
LightSquared bishop and Spassky now asks
pressure what is your plan with the
bishop we have g4 here and here better
back to e6 this is a very nice moment
because here gligar rich in the book
mentions that Bishop captures night here
would have been a much safer approach
allowing whites to create such a such an
active game but the engine agrees with
Fisher's idea brush up to e6 and
disregarding the fact that white will
now have a very active game so okay
tonight's the d4 a very nice central
square for the night spassky's two
central nights are now
well at least compensation for the pawn
if nothing else
brush up the C for attacking spassky's
Queen and now comes Queen to d2 saying
that okay Fischer if you capture my pawn
on e5 I will capture a pawn on h6
captures captures and if you bring the
bishop back
I'll just go Queen to b3 and now Knight
to d5 after this attack on the Queen
Queen to d2 and in fact this this would
be okay for for Fischer but still and
does it really do anything other than
weaken your King side hard to say after
this so Queen to d2 Fischer goes Queen
to d7 and now we have rook a to d1 again
the e5 pawn is not free for grabs
rook F to e 8 and the now comes f4
Spassky decides to go all-out rush up to
d5 and now we have Knight the c5
attacking Fischer's Queen Queen back to
c8 and this is the 25th move of the game
where Spassky spent a lot of time and he
played the Queen to c3 and Fischer
mentioned after the game that he really
felt uncertainty here during Spassky
screen to see to remove and all the
commentators I've seen an annotation of
this game by vasily smyslov also the one
by a surly garage everyone points out
this ECX idea and ECX is a very powerful
idea and Shirley's possibly spent a lot
of time in the game calculating it but
he decided against it it's a very nice
idea because as the main line goes nice
to see for attacking the Queen on D -
Queen to e2 and now Knight captures on
b2 with an attack on the rook on d1 and
now Knight to f5 this is the move
Smith's love mentions that it's really
really a powerful idea because now it
doesn't really matter what black does if
he captures the knight then comes
rook captures on d5 you you grab the
piece back and dime
much better here with white after you
block the pawn here comes g5 and the
white is breaking through here and on
the other hand after this Knight to f5
move if we don't capture the night if
you decide to grab the rook then again a
very nice variation knife captures on g7
pink after Sun g7 and now Queen to e5
check f6 blocking and now Queen captures
on d5 grabbing the piece back and after
the knight moves attacks the Queen now
comes Queen to c4 with a with a really
wild position you can't really do
anything to protect the knight on c3 and
after something like g5 pawn captures
pawn captures white can either play even
play Bishop captures on g5 f captors and
now after Queen captures on c3 this
comes with check King to h7 and now
comes this rook to e5 move and with
maneuvers like Knights to e4 and
capturing and g5 it would be a very
promising position for white so I mean
it's a very longer variation and it's
very hard to decide to go for this in a
World Chess Championship match game but
it was definitely the way to go as it
was mentioned after the game but okay
after Queen to see it's pasta goes Queen
to c3 and now Fischer as he saw that
Spassky hesitated to push East X pushes
East six himself and now there is no
more each sex for Spassky King to h2 you
have to bring your King into the game it
will be much safer on g3 Knight to d7
and here Spassky avoids the trade nights
to d3 but avoiding the trader will allow
Fischer to further develop his pieces
because now Fischer finds c5 and okay we
have nice to b5 and now comes Queen to
c6 and now there's really another good
square for this night Spassky has to
play a Knight to d6 and now Fischer
takes this opportunity to play Queen
captures on d6 forcing the trade of
Queens he captures on d6 Bishop captures
on c3 pawn captures on c3 and now comes
f6
simply improving his pawn structure and
white will be unable to push for
anything here still Fisheries of
material with a better endgame it will
be very hard for Spassky
to figure this out so g5 Spassky decides
to fight for the dark squares H captors
and g5f captures and g5 and now f5 and
ok Russia back to g3 we have King to f7
Fischer brings his King into the game
but now Knight to e5 would check Spassky
thinks that his best bet is to go into
an opposite color Bishop endgame and
tried to fight this out to a draw Knight
captures on e5 would have Bishop
captures on e5 and now b5 by Fischer of
course he is stronger on the Queen side
so that is where he wants to play this
game
rook to f1 a very nice move because now
it's it's a very tricky move as passkeys
Bishop is extremely strong here covering
the HHH we're now officially simply
tries to push his passport for the
victory
you get rook to f4 pawn to a2 rooted h4
and now if you bring the Queen into the
game rook to h7 check ensures that white
will have a draw by threefold repetition
because the point is covering the f6 and
d7 Square and here a black doesn't
really have any choice here okay shade
check hooking f7 location 7 check King
j-rock AJ check and there will be a draw
by threefold repetition so I have to
look to f1 rope create a very nice move
by Fischer he offers to sacrifice the
exchange and as spassky's Bishop is
definitely the most active piece and the
strongest piece and then Fischer's
light-square bishop will be after this
pawn comes to a2 will be too much to
handle for the rooks so Spassky decides
against capturing the rook which is
definitely the correct way to go
Bishop to f6 and okay we have a three by
Fischer rock to f4 we have a two and
here as possibly has to make his 40th
move to reach time control and it's very
important that it will be a correct move
if you play something like rook to a1 to
keep an eye on this pawn then e 5 will
be a very nice move for black after Luke
2 F 2 into e6 and even better captures
rook captures will not be all that much
white can try something like rook to d2
with the idea that if King captures then
c4 will force black double his pawns but
rook to d8 simply prepares to grab the
d6 pawn and white it doesn't really have
anything here to do he would have to
give up the exchange back and after ten
captures to grab dat look but then after
rook captures black would be a pawn up
and with a much better pawn structure
which to the seat the seat bones being
doubled for white I would be a winning
endgame for black and this is evaluated
correctly so far so as poss he pushes c4
with c4 Spassky makes his 40th move
reaches time control and now Fischer
still has to work hard for his meal
butcher captures on c4 it's definitely
the correct way to go if you play this
then you're no longer guarding da to
pawn and also you'll have some ideas
like d7 for white and then after c3 if
you want to reactivate your bishop then
comes a bunch of chapters on h8 rook
captures and then rook to a for not
allowing this rook to ever come back to
8 or you can you can trade it but then
really it will be very hard to push for
something here so a correct response by
Fischer after c4 Bishop captures on c4
now comes d7 and now brush it back to d5
and here Spassky has to make his move
before sealing the move that he will
seal so the game has to be adjourned
here it will be continued tomorrow and
it has to be a very nice move busca
plays King to g3 he wants the guard
against any rook to a3 ideas cutting off
the King from the board here the engine
definitely agrees with Spassky and
Fischer spent the entire night analyzing
this position it was William Lombardi
Fischer seconds and said that he never
saw Fischer analyzing any endgame any
adjourned game as much as he did
analyzing this game and that they really
had a force Fischer to go to sleep
because he would simply keep analyzing
it that they were afraid that if he
analyzes it too much that he will be too
tired to play tomorrow but the game was
supposed to be continued tomorrow
afternoon and Fischer was half an hour
late to the continuation of the game but
ok Fischer finally arrived and he played
rook to a3 as he did spend the entire
night analyzing
the game so some 16 moves of the game
were part of his home analysis for this
entire continuation c3 blocking check
and now comes Rock h2 a8 rook to h4
again you can promote to the Queen
because rook to h7 is definitely a
threat that would ensure a Spassky to
get a draw and here comes a Fischer move
Fischer's move that he found in home
analysis it's the only move that allows
black to play for victory so feel free
to pause the video here you don't have
to spend the entire night here analyzing
it but as you do know that there is
something here perhaps you will you will
find it so how does black push for
something more than a draw here for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations and especially
congratulations if you haven't spent the
entire night searching for it and for
those who just want to enjoy the show
e5 a very nice pawn sacrifice by Fischer
that creates a room for Ace King an
escape route to be a king to e6 and the
d6 now rope to h7 does not ensure a spa
ski a draw well it might but it does
lose a piece for Fischer so this is
basically not only a pawn sacrifice but
also a piece sacrificed by Fischer and
Spassky goes for it there's really
nothing better to do here look to h7
check King to e6 now comes look to e7
check King box and now comes the rook
captures on e5 and now as the bishop
here is pinned Fischer will lose a piece
here but this is all part of his home
preparation
route captures on c3 now we have king -
f2 as the king was in check and now rook
the C to check King to e1 and now
there's no more ways to prolong
capturing the bishop so simply capture
the past pawn king capture son d7 rookie
capture Sundy I would check King to c6
and rook to d6 check this is all still
part of facials on preparation King - b7
group to d7 check King to a6 and only
now rook back to D to recapture some d2
routine capture son d2 and Dena comes
before so now for his sacrifice piece
Fischer has three passed pawns soon to
be connected so definitely compensation
for the piece and Spassky in this
position pushes h4
definitely the way to go and it's the
active idea he wants to push h5 and
create a passed pawn of his own either
by pushing it to h6
or Fisher will capture and then the g6
pawn the Jeep on becomes a passed pawn
here we have came to b5 by Fischer h5 as
planned by Spassky c4 now and now look
to a1 a much needed more if you push to
h5 then c3 comes with check and the
bishop is no longer guarding the a1
square so look to a 1 you have to waste
a move here and now G captures on h5 g 6
by Spassky and we have h4 by Fischer and
now Fischer has another pass pawn as
well here Fischer actually has five pass
bones so that's that's really a lot g7
we have h3 and the Bishop to e7 now
Fischer is the one that has to waste a
move if he plays any move that that
that's not the move he played then it's
well c3 he can go for c3 but any other
move than that he has to block it with
the rook because passkeys threatening
Bishop to f8 and the rook will no longer
be controlling the g8 square so Spassky
will be able to promote his pawn
so rock to g8 blocking this idea but now
Bishop to f8 now Spassky traps Fischer's
rook h2 by Fischer and now comes came to
see two spots T has to bring his King
over to defend all of against all of
these pawns and then perhaps the rook
can come over here and stuff start
picking up the other pawns King back to
see sits by Fischer we have rook to d1
cutting off fresh horse king and now b3
would check King the c3 kind of a
mistake as possible leaders find that
the king will be much better on b2 and
here comes a move that that everyone
characterized as why Fischer was so
strong here f4 is the best move to play
and everyone knew this and did the
engine even says that this is the best
move but it eventually it will lead to a
draw after rook to d6 check King to c7
and now rogue back to d1 there's really
nothing to do here so Fisher finds a way
that allows him to fight again for
something more than a draw he plays h1
and promotes his pawn to a Queen rook
afters on h1 and now comes King to d2
would this
pawn sacrifice official now makes makes
room for his King to enter the game
supposed to place King to be - he has to
waste a move and now comes f4 rook to d1
check pink to e4 and now comes look to
see one fresh replace came to d3 and
here's passkeys again in a very big time
trouble he has that he has four more
minutes for the creator to make four
more moves and with his next move
Spassky makes a pretty big blunder would
Rock the c3 check the game still could
have been drawn after came to e2 rook
can capture on c4 and now f3 will be met
with the rook to e4 check and now if
King goes here then he will block his
own pawn and if the King moves back for
example kingi to king D - or King D 1
then rook comes to DF file threatens the
window pawn but instead after this game
to be to remove Spassky played rook to
d1 check instead of rook to c3 check
here we have King to e2 and now comes
Luke 2 c1 simply wasting another move
but now the c4 pawn was not captured
with tempo here F 3
we have rush up to c5 and here rook to
g7 capturing the pawn rook captures on
c4 and now rook to d7 again Fischer
makes this move instantly he doesn't
allow for f2 and Bishop captures on f2
which could perhaps in the long run
allow white some chances for a draw but
rather rook to d7 now cutting off
spassky's pieces as passkey tries rook
to e4 check but now we have pink - f1
rush up to d4 and now comes
f2 and it was actually in this position
unmoved 74 that the world chess champion
Boris Spassky decided to resign the game
he resigned because now there's really
not all that much to do here whatever
you play let's say capturing the pond
now doesn't really give you any chances
for a draw because
rook the d2 check and now you believe
either move the king and allow a want to
come with check or you will block it and
then rub the d1 will force the King back
and now you can get a queen and it's a
lower on the other hand after f2 if you
try something like group 2f
for now do you see Fisher's idea of
course you do it's rook captures on D
for rope captures and simply came to
Jeju now there's no way to prevent point
to f1 I mean there is a way you can do
this but you then after rope capture
screen captures
even though White's King is cutting off
the pawns from advancing there's no way
to actually do anything if you capture
it
black will simply grab a queen and win
the game so I'll move 74 after F to
Spassky resigned and another great
victory for for the Challenger Bobby
Fischer who furthers his lead now the
three points in this match and it's very
interesting both unique and also
petrosyan said that they were very very
impressed with Fischer's play Botvinnik
mentioned that it was supposed to be
Fischer would be struggling in this
match you know with everything and with
their showing his emotions and the whole
psychology of the match he said that one
of Fischer's weaknesses was playing long
matches and that he simply wouldn't have
it in him
but the Fischer show did the exact
opposite and but Rosen said that as
Pascal would be the one that would be
forcing Fischer to play a whole variety
of different openings different styles
different systems but as we've seen here
it's actually Fischer who keeps
surprising Spassky with with everything
mentioned so that's game 13 I do hope
you enjoyed it pretty big blow for four
world champion Boris Spassky we'll see
how the game of how the match continues
I would like to thank my roof Ashgar
Daniel bond Gregor Crawford Damian
Jewett and Dan O'Hanlon for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos your
thing call for watching and I'll see you
soon hopefully with some more
interesting content thank you all and
have an excellent rest of the Friday